my guest this week is an anti regressive
bounty hunter a youtuber and a Twitter
warrior
unfortunately he thinks Star Trek is
better than Star Wars but nobody's
perfect
I'll let Akash walk up to the show
thanks T thanks for having me
so I'm very excited to sit down with you
because we've been doing this in 140
characters for about a year now yeah and
we're gonna we're gonna go a little more
than 140 characters yeah I think it'll
be good I think it's a it's good to get
deeper into it yeah so we're gonna do a
lot of regressive stuff we're going to
talk some farm policy all kinds of stuff
but first I want to do a little bit on
your history because you live in Chile
yeah you're in LA I think right now for
the first time in about 10 years or 10
years yeah I have that back and you were
born here I was born here so I'm
basically back home but you know I I was
born in in the US in LA my parents were
both immigrants from Chile my father
went to UCLA study physics there and
then when I was about 12 we moved back
to Chile I'd never been there before
prior to the move then I you know I grew
up there and then I decided to come back
to the US for college went to UCLA and
then I just went on this kind of you
know journey of education and travel I
went to Korea and studied at Yonsei
University then lived in Japan for a
while then went back to Chile and
missing my family because you know Chile
two ages very far that's a long trip
that's a long trip you know like 30 hour
flight so I decided to go back and then
even there I went to university to get a
postgraduate degree in international
relations and I studied all kinds of
things in Korea I studied language in
Santa Barbara I studied film studies so
it's been this kind of big thing I never
really did much more than educate myself
up you know pretty much so it is kind of
serendipitous that I kind of there was a
mark you know there were I just kind of
lost it with uh with what happened with
Sam Harris
yeah I'm Ben Affleck and I had never had
like any kind of social social media
presence yeah they were on online but I
felt there I had to do something about
it you know it being I was taught I was
educating myself about politics I got
very interested in interested in from
traveling and
I become aware of like Christopher
Hitchens Richard Dawkins Sam Harris
specifically Sam Harris after Richard
after Christopher Hitchens who was more
the political side but then hey Sam
Harris started getting into the
political aspects I know this is an
interesting guy
yeah but before we get I and I know
you're jumping I'm jumping I'll be on oh
yeah so so we had never met before
because you were Olivia yeah I've been
on your podcast and we tweet all the
time right you had dinner the other
night and we had about four hours of we
we laid it out with the regressive so
we're gonna try until the restaurant
closed literally we were the layout lots
of people out yeah they kicked us out
but we're gonna try to recreate some of
that conversation because I think we hit
on all the things that are important to
us yeah but before we get into some of
that first I just want to realist rate
what you just said is you're actually
educated in some of this stuff you're
not just some guy some Twitter avatar
tweeting that some of the stuff you've
studied foreign policy you've traveled
the world you've studied film I mean
even that is it's related into some of
this narrative and all that
representation what's going on with you
know you know it with the Oscars you
know there's a lot of identity because
to me I went to Korea because I was
studying Korean film that's what I
specialized in and I learned culture and
history from that yeah and that you know
gave me the enthusiasm to learn more
about politics and culture about other
places so you know film even is a lot
about that yeah so I think it's just
important to say that because there's so
many people that put themselves out
there and it's like do you actually know
anything that you're talk about yeah are
you educated at any of this yeah I mean
I studied politics but who you know
there's so many people just talking and
it's nice to know that you're talking to
somebody that has some background in
some of the stuff but you also you're
your family background I find really
fascinating and I learned something
about it the other night that I didn't
know so your grandfather I think on your
father's side so your great-grandfather
is he was Palestinian correct yes he my
great-grandfather on my father's side
came from Palestine early 20th century
despite what a lot of people think the
first mass migration of Palestinians
were came because under the Ottoman
Empire right and they were mostly
Christians so that's an interesting
piece because I think most people I
don't want to get too into the history
of that because then we could write yeah
talking for eight hours but a lot of
people to understand that that land was
controlled by the Ottoman Empire when
basically today is Turkey and then after
a World War one it was then controlled
by the British for about 50 years and
then since 48 the whole area has been
split up eighteen different ways but you
know I thought I said to see the other
night I thought that your family was
Muslim be I get that a lot just because
you said you said that you have
Palestinian ancestry now I know for all
that I know that's a pretty it's a
pretty silly thing for me to say because
at one time there were a lot of
Palestinian Christians there actually
aren't anymore right yeah yeah so it's
it's a good thing like to point out that
the fourth largest population of pasta
means in the world is in Chile it's the
largest population outside the Middle
East I think it's like Jordan Syria and
the fourth is Chile yeah and it has half
a million Palestinians and basically
across the board atoll people who came
from Orthodox Christian background yeah
and now they a lot of them has converted
to Catholicism which is the religion of
the country for many over many
generations yeah do you do you feel like
Palestinian Christians are sort of lost
in this whole mess because even for the
act and until two days ago I just
assumed that your family was Muslim is
sort of interesting because I think it
has well don't talk about Palestinian
Christians I think it has a lot to do
with where they emigrated to because in
Chile there's not a lot of conflict and
and I think it has a lot to do with the
fact that there are not Muslim
Palestinians so the Jewish community in
Chile and the Palestinian community have
no problem right right because it's just
like nobody really cares and there's not
really problems of like a religious
terrorism or anything so it's very like
pluralistic and kind of meshed together
more people care about economics and you
know the political sphere but that's a
there's about half a million pasta
people of Palestinian background into
that's twice as much as the Palestinians
in the United States mm-hmm but they
have a larger voice in the u.s. right
but Palestinians and Christian
Palestinian in Chile how are kind of you
know put aside and and people assume
that they are synonymous Palestinian and
and Muslim yeah and I don't think it
should be like that it would be like
saying Christian is synonymous to
American and I think people a lot of
people say well that's even kind of a
offensive right and but it's kind of
accepted a lot of people on the left
would say that yeah but even a lot of
people on the Left who consider
themselves liberals are very happy to
kind of mesh together Arab in general
with Muslim and I don't think that
should be done yeah and it's funny how
it's funny how people conflate that
because I've even seen you one time
arguing with another Palestinian on
Twitter oh yeah I'm sick Liam I don't
want to mention again yeah he he
basically said well your it was
something the effect of like you're not
a real Palestinian or you're not exactly
that something today you're not a real
Palestinian yeah and I thought you know
not only is that that's actually
offensive like saying that my history
isn't my history because I don't believe
the same things but I think you were
illuminating a point about terrorism
related to that that there are right now
for the few Christians that remain in
the West Bank they aren't stabbing
people and blowing things up so there is
some religious component yeah to that
that's separate the national identities
do you think that's fair to say oh
absolutely so you know actually I have
some still family a you know distant
family but still family I talked to who
like you know might have an uncle in
Chile and his like he has a some like
cousins and things like that who live in
Israel and partly in in Palestine and I
you know I hear about them all the time
the hardest it is for them in in Israel
yeah is because of discrimination from
Palestinian Muslims right not not from
Israelis right so meaning that they're
citizens the ones that live in is wrap
up our citizens of the State of Israel
yeah and they have my Christian Arab
citizens of the State of Israel right
and they're forgotten like you've
pointed out many times the minorities of
the minorities are the most forgotten
people actually and they face the
sometimes the hardest criticism but i
think sam harris is pointed this out
it's almost like an experiment going on
where you have you know the same
basically the same people with a
different religion in the same situation
but only one of them are acting a
certain way yeah and I mean even into
like my family my family's background is
Orthodox Christian in background but my
grandfather my father my brother my you
know my
my whole family all atheists right right
so it's not really to me even religion
as a connection to my heritage you know
just just in a in a kind of ancestry way
I know that they were Orthodox
Christians coming here but it's not
something I relate to and I feel it's
okay to feel like a connection to being
Palestinian and not the religious aspect
and I think it's the same for a lot of
Jews as well a lot of Jews are like you
know I I love a lot of the tradition I
practice a lot of it and I love that
that I have this Jewish background but
the religion doesn't really mean much to
me it's nice and it's great having it
there but I you know but you know I have
it's not great it's irrelevant a
thousand times I'm not religious don't
hold me to it
like Curb Your Enthusiasm and bagels
that's good you know yeah all right well
I'm glad we we did a little of that
because I think it's good for people to
yes and it also explains partly why when
we first connected on Twitter I thought
there was something so interesting about
you because your original Twitter handle
was Chile's atheist right yeah yeah and
it said something about being a
Palestinian Chilean a theist something
yeah I was like wow this guy's got a lot
like there's a lot in there and I think
and then a short while after you
eventually change it to your actual name
la la de gosh right I think was an
important moment for you right yeah no I
decided to kind of cut that out a lot
one is because I felt like there is a
responsibility to use your your real
name and also I kind of wanted to get
out the kind of the identity politics of
it but I was aware of the fact that by
putting those aspects out there
Chilean and Palestinian is not as easy
for a lot of the regressives who we'll
talk about later
to cut me down and they tried like I got
people tweeting me saying I don't think
like so I would present an argument to
them right and I would show evidence and
their response to me is saying I don't
think you're in Chile I don't think I
don't think you are who you see or now
right why do these LA by you Craig I
didn't even ask a thing where's that on
their list of France's or something so
and now at one point I even took a video
of myself like I was at a courthouse and
I took a video like Chile's courthouse
in the back to like show like I am Who I
am but why do they do that because they
want they even said I think you're in
the US now if I was now they have
something to attack me with
now it's like oh you're you're in the
u.s. you're you're white you're not
Palestinian right you're the typical
person I can cut down you know I can say
oh you know this is white privilege you
don't know what you're talking about
it's not easy to do that with somebody
like Maajid Nawaz I and her CLE though
they try they they try they will do it
anyway they will do it anyway but um but
yeah it doesn't it doesn't come from a
place that like I believe in white
supremacy or I'm a right-wing
conservative you know these are my
family's the most classical liberals
there are like you know if we can go
down the list you know against
homophobia against racism yeah freedom
of speech you know all the other things
that like Bill Maher says you know I'm
just your classical liberal I just
believe in the right ideas liberal ideas
yeah and this showdown really the power
of science because I think you said to
me your grandfather was a physicist my
grandfather's a fair father also a
physicist my brother also died there
I have an uncle worked for NASA for a
while and that shows yeah I mean right
there it's almost like you don't need
much more from this whole conversation
to show that the power of science people
that have to believe in reality and have
to believe in quantifiable things based
on evidence actually all the other stuff
the identity stuff all the rest of it
sort of melts away
yeah really base things in science yeah
I mean my father was like oh he's always
proud like you know he comes from a
Palestinian background you know he's
happy he comes from from Chile you know
all the kind of identity without the
identity politics he likes the the
identity but he doesn't take positions
based on though that's identity politics
right right I am a Palestinian therefore
I'm against you know Israel Jews know my
father you know he evaluates things
based on the evidence and the facts yeah
so it you know even the people I grew up
admiring I think I told you before you
know Albert Einstein Richard Fineman
Carl Sagan the voices of reason where
Jewish people I didn't know at the time
when I was little were Jewish because I
father's just doesn't talk that way and
by the way none of those people were
religious none of them are religious
that's the interesting and they could
care less yeah about the identity you
know it's like if my father sat down
with one any other scientist of any
other background they would probably
only get emotional about physics
and I've seen that they get into
arguments and I've seen you know you
know plates for the fly but for physics
you know like this is the evidence right
they they don't care about like the and
isn't a scientist in general like that
they don't care right don't care well
that's why you know for all the time
that I've spent here talking about
religion it's like I think it's so
ridiculous like at the end of the day I
think religion is utterly ridiculous
right and yet I've had to address it
because it's been latched on to so much
related to politics and everything else
hmm but yet I'm talking about something
that fundamentally I think is
nonsensical we had a conversation about
Israel Palestine the first time we I
asked you to speak with me on video and
we're talking about Israel Palestine
we're we try to like basically look at
it in the most rational logical way
possible yeah and from like our
different backgrounds but ultimately we
have a good conversation because we we
care about facts what's going on here
now it's difficult to come to any
conclusion because we're looking for a
rational conclusion in an irrational
situation right with the rational actors
and we're and we're trying to look at it
in the most rational way possible and
ultimately we're not going to have be
that successful so that's interesting
because actually of all the times I've
ever debated the Middle East with anyone
the conversation with you I actually
usually I end them and I'm like [ __ ] one
right and that again because you get
nowhere you get nowhere and people as we
know with their regressives they like
narrative over facts so even if you give
them facts that that's scared then they
just get angry usually right but we had
a really interesting thorough
conversation it's on your channel on
YouTube so I welcome anyone to watch it
and it gets away from it leaves you with
a feeling like alright we don't know the
answers but let's let's talk let's see
how far we can evolve with this thing
right ya know well so let's talk about
the the other issues that that we like
so much with a brought us here well
you're giving me the signal I am yeah
yeah I'm like hammer you mean say yeah
that's good ok so you had your awakening
I think with all of this and with what's
happened on the left is very similar to
mine yeah and it had a lot to do with
the the ben affleck sam harris thing and
even as i say it now i think you know we
we've talked this into oblivion already
talked about it with Sargon
week gonna keep talking about it but I
think it's important because it was such
a monumental moment for so many people
so throwing the so yeah I think I think
there was actually two events that
really split the entire left outside of
the right wing which you know as
classical liberals we are like okay you
know The Daily Show kind of band forget
it we don't we don't care right but on
the daily shows guys are ridiculous guys
are ridiculous we can laugh about fox
news all day but then like okay now we
have our little circle and what's going
on here and basically with 9/11 and this
is you can get a lot from like what
Christopher Hitchens was saying that he
used to be very on on par with a Noam
Chomsky and a lot of other people in
politics and after 9/11 it kind of split
there and they basically the the
political divide was did this happen
because of just American foreign policy
and it's we're responsible for this it's
just payback or is there something also
intrinsically wrong with culture and
religion and a mentality that they're
bringing there and that was a political
split but then I think that the politics
kind of bled into this kind of new
social justice regressive kind of
mentality and I got I saw some little
glimpses of it I saw people telling me
like you know well I would say I've read
the Quran I didn't enjoy it and people
told me you're racist for that I'm a
racist because I read a book and I
didn't like it am i racist against the
you know fifty shades of gray because I
didn't like it right you know so so then
I think the the peak of that was Ben
Affleck with sam Harris so you know sam
Harris comes on there you've gone over
this a million times it goes on there we
have to be able to criticize bad ideas
but you know but we shouldn't be bigoted
against specifically people you know
it's new we can still be respectful of
people respect their freedom of speech
you know look at them individually but
we can look at ideologies and say you
know there's something yeah wrong and
then quoted polls to show yeah certain
amount of people believing certain
things yeah I mean the the polls are
they're just put in Islam and into Pew
Research and look at the data there you
know support for Sharia law support a
support for
for gay marriage or acceptability of
homosexuality abortion rights it should
women be able to dress the way they want
you just go down the list and Muslim
states are just awful
and it's not just like 5050 like we're
talking like 90 I sent you the recently
the one with about acceptance of
homosexuality and the kind like in
Muslim states that they are accepting of
homosexuality was like 0% 0% 1% 2% and
and we're talking dozens of countries
yeah we're talking hundreds of millions
of people right so Ben Affleck throw I'm
sorry Sam Harris throws that out and Ben
athlete calls from a racist essentially
that's not a big deal
because just okay Ben Affleck is just
you know there's nobody's talking about
what really bothered me was the next day
and I said I used to be a fan of The
Young Turks you used to be on there and
I thought okay jank I like jank he's
gonna he's gonna tear this down and no
he sides with Ben Affleck and I see the
view they're signing with Ben Affleck
all these shows all these liberals
people who's like I'm four you know you
know against homophobia I'm for women's
rights and we're talking about the
places where it's the most problematic
right now despite what anything reza
aslan says it is that way right no get
over it yeah it exists everywhere but
we're talking in a spectrum where is it
the worst you know where was it best so
to be clear they suddenly were siding
with the guy who just threw out the red
meat I mean it's just the easy answer
that sounds good makes you feel good
right they're racist versus the guys who
have consistently stood for liberal
values in this case being Bill Maher so
so why why did this happen I think and
it's good to kind of look back obviously
I okay they were aggressive we didn't
like what Ben Affleck said a lot of
people sided with him but what exactly
happened in these last few years what I
think happened is kind of it was
multiculturalism going off the rails so
you have kind of two roads intersecting
one is where people who you know we kind
of grew up on this idea of
multiculturalism that it's good to be
accepting of people of other
nationalities other cultures other
religions and okay that's a good idea
but at the same time we're against
racism homophobia and all this stuff so
we have this crossroads where okay we
have to be accepting of other cultures
but it turns out the a lot of these
cultures are some of them have some of
the worst liberal values we've seen
they're extremely conservative the very
homophobic they're very against women's
rights right and then okay what do I do
here and a lot of liberal mines exploded
they went nuts they went nuts like what
what do I do in this case I am supposed
to be super tolerant yeah or I'm
supposed to call out liberal values and
and what happened was that there was an
ad 'vine right and there's the people
and I think there's also you could throw
in conservatives they're the
conservative message is like okay what's
happening here is that all these people
are just backwards and stupid and it's
intrinsic to who they are yeah you know
the Donald Trump now side of the
argument right but then the other
extreme is to say no what we have to do
is never criticize these people for
these things are doing and I think the
middle road yeah is you me sam harris
saying we can be multicultural and
tolerant and against racism we can do
all these things and at the same time we
can call out the cultures for their
liberal values which is even the code
like i'd like for people to call out
chile even for their liberal values
please do it you know there's there's a
lot of problems there it's one of the
few countries where abortion is illegal
across the board even if the mother's
life is in danger
absolutely and it's completely related
to Catholicism and religion please talk
about that you know they call it out I
know it's it's a small countries it's
not write up on the board but I wouldn't
like you're not gonna get to it next
week right right oh you're not being
racist for talking about it it doesn't
hurt me yeah right it's not like Oh
Chileans are all backwards now knows
like we all have our problems right
right yeah so that moment it was clearly
big for me it was big for you yeah it
was big for a lot of people you get
online and you started taking down the
people that you felt were giving bad
ideas and this was really before I was
still working at the Young Turks at the
time this was before my awakening it
sort of fully formed and I became aware
of a couple people like you and I was
like Jesus here's this guy half a world
away that I know nothing about that sort
of Inanna
yeah Palestinian I don't know what's
going on here but this guy's braver than
me right now and that's where I was
interested in you and I thought you use
technology you used all the tools of
social media primarily to expose this
stuff so that must been very empowering
for you well it wasn't my idea to be
empowering at first sight I did I that
happened the same I think in the same
two weeks that Sam Harris thing happened
I made a video on YouTube I've never
made a video on YouTube I wrote a blog
never written a blog yeah and I didn't
know what to do with these like who but
essentially I want to talk with people I
needed to know I'm not insane that I'm
still liberal I that I can't it can't be
that I'm racist yeah and I looked for a
community and I found it on Twitter and
I just started posting and as you've
seen like in a very certain way I posted
clips of people saying certain things
and it would be easy to me easy for me
to go on there and just attack these
people and call them you're racist
you're Nazis but no let these people
speak for themselves and what the great
thing was is that people really call to
people you know a lot of people rallied
to me I didn't expect to like it the
following I did but I I suspected that
these people needed a voice and I'm just
one voice among many now it's you and
Bill Maher's right up there you had saw
gone on before and people are hungry for
it because they feel like I am a real
liberal these people are not and no one
is speaking for me yeah well I think
maybe that's why the the real time thing
was so interesting because the second he
said racist I thought I didn't I i've
told samus when he sat in a chair I
didn't really know who Sam was before
that I had never read any of his books I
sort of ancillary known him but I
thought here's a guy who just said the
truth he just quoted some polls
something innately simple and basic
right he said nothing anything you
didn't say anything racist or even
bigoted he coated a couple polls right
and here's a pretty measured guy who's
not worked up and whatever yeah he was
just trying to lay out some numbers and
when he said racist and I'm thinking I
agree with this guy I'm not a racist yes
so we put the onus on me and I think
that's what you mean about the next day
why the next day was so interesting yeah
because the next day was all the all the
online sites were like Bill Maher's
erases sam Harris racism right nobody oh
thank you
exactly I needed to say because I felt
no one else was saying it yeah right and
that you told me like later that you
kind of first avoided the subject right
for a while yeah and then you you
decided no this needs to be talked about
yeah and P and people needed to be
talked about because they're out there
they're on in their couches and in their
chairs watching what's going on online
and essentially like you said like when
Ben Affleck called
Sam Harris or racist and and so many
people on the Left agreed with that like
can I'm a racist and I'm not I'm the
most libguide right there is the guys
can't be what what the message is yeah
and by the way I don't know if the video
that we did a couple weeks ago with Lube
Nachman is up as we tape this right
right yeah I don't know if we have that
video up right now because she's under
threat so this is a secular atheist so I
think this gets to the heart of this
this is a secular atheist who was
promoting women's rights and human
rights in Iraq a very hard place to do
this right um and I'm talking to her
because I believe in those liberal
principles and whereas the people to our
left
now the regressives they wouldn't talk
to someone like her because it makes it
flips the the script on them and they
don't know what to do with someone like
her so they just ignore all those people
right I don't know her too well but look
at someone like I am yeah right like
she's from Somalia a black woman she had
you know she went through female genital
mutilation she she was almost in a
forced marriage and then she she has
this enlightenment this awakening as you
say as well and she's like you know
she's all about atheism and she believes
in reason and the alignment and she goes
around saying the most rational thing
there is that she's against religion I
think it's harmful yeah and I don't
think that's a controversial point of
view it doesn't mean you're against you
know religious people specifically right
it's like I'm against Maajid Nawaz right
and his belief of God doesn't mean I'm
against Majid Nawaz is a person I think
he's great right but I would vote for
this guy if you ran for president ok so
that's a really beautiful right you're
making that so Majin was as far as we
know he believes in God he believed yeah
trying to reform Islam because he is
Muslim I agree with 99 percent exactly I
said
so that's the we are against Maajid
Nawaz we uptick right in that once I
don't like for him to get that way but
yes yes I see that's a problem you don't
like framing it that way why because it
sounds like you have this big antagonism
towards them let's take being against
gay marriage you probably know people
yeah it will
and you probably you like or against gay
marriage Yeah right and do you like
alright what to what degree are you
opposed to these people on just that
subject right and I'm opposed to Medina
was on that one little subjects yeah for
every other reason it's like it's fine
but the gay marriage thing is
interesting because you know five years
ago when gay marriage wasn't legal it's
not like everyone that didn't believe in
it was a was a bigot but now they would
frame it as if everyone who hasn't fully
gotten there yet progress takes time
right but the left would make it seem
that everyone who was in a hundred
percent for gay marriage at the moment
which obviously I'm for right yeah they
would have you believe that they're all
bigots and that's just that's just silly
people evolve over time five years ago
Barack Obama wasn't for games yeah
exactly so I so that well let's look at
like two people let's take an atheist
who you know he's he's homophobic he's
racist he's a jerk he's uneducated but
he doesn't believe in God now let's take
Maajid Nawaz right Maajid Nawaz believes
in God as far as we know but you know
he's for freedom of speech you know he's
for a yeast for every liberal value
there is who would you rather have a
retainer right right so it's just that
one subject you know that we're kind of
against you know and that we have to see
on a spectrum because his belief in God
is not the same as an Isis person's
belief in God a person who's homophobic
it's very different when you're like
okay you know I don't have any real
problem with home sick I just don't
think they should get married that's
very different from from throwing gays
off rooftops like Isis does yeah so I'm
against homophobia I'm against belief in
God but on a spectrum it depends on how
you we apply these things yeah right so
so when you got involved in sort of
exposing some of these people do you
ever think it would get this far where
you'd be really in it at the level you
are because you're right if I'm in the
thick of this thing you're in the thick
of this never occurred to me yeah and I
never never occurred to me it's it's
bizarre but I think it's it's a lack of
voices maybe I also think it's it's that
I prepared myself a lot unknowingly
participated in this you know it's good
to come at this with a lot of evidence
and education not because I'm
particularly smart but because the
people who follow me are smart because
they they they know their facts they
know their background and like I need
somebody who's just not screaming out
racist yeah because that doesn't mean
anything you know you this you've gone
over this with Sargon and other people
but yeah it's it's it is just it's an
irrelevant attack and it's to the point
where I'm saying that people are being
called racist and they are the smartest
person in the room oh sorry
it's starting to meet seem to me that
the person in a room with five people
who's called races is probably the
person who's writing the score and
tomorrow right which is such an
unfortunate
it's horrible yeah yeah it's a horrible
position for us to be put in because as
Douglas Murray said to unsay my respire
because it's too late to be offended by
these people I'm roughly yeah but their
cries it's like the boy who cried wolf
they've lied so many times there's
nothing left there's another left so so
we should have no fear this is what I've
been what I want my audience to really
understand because when I'm getting
these messages where people are saying
I'm afraid to say what I think and I
live in the United States well meanwhile
I'm talking to Lublin in Iraq who who
has real risk you know and it's like if
you live in the West and you're afraid
to say what you think now what's it
going to be like in five years
well you've pointed out I think in the
past how it's amazing how the Atheist
community online is all anonymous yes
what do you make of that well I think it
still just is very hard to come out as
as an atheist you know despite what a
lot of people say I've met I've talked
with people online and they just don't
want to participate in on this online
conversation it's like I can't talk
about religion I can't say I'm an
atheist for my job now what Christian or
even Muslim or any of any religion is
going to say I can't say I can't even
say they just say I'm a Muslim can't put
it in there like with their name on the
Twitter counter on their face book it
says Muslim yeah or Christian or Jew but
if you put atheists on there it's
problematic for for your work please
died that that's really hard and shows
like there's a certain reflection and
you know the statistics show that still
you know atheists are the most distrust
people that the least likely American is
to vote way below gay or Muslim or if
you smoke weed or women the worst is
atheists right and we know weed is
pretty bad I can't believe this we have
to wrap this thing up already we okay
barely scratch the surger so I'm gonna
have you on again in a couple days we're
gonna do a sit-down with with Dada Dada
sad who's a great guy who you've also
connected with on Twitter and we'll do
it we'll do a lot more on all of this so
I hope that was a little intro to to
start this whole thing from happening so
I want to thank Allah for joining me you
can follow him on the Twitter at Lalo de
gosh oh and expect a big announcement
from him coming pretty soon all right
thanks for watching we'll do it again
next week
you